واشنطن تتوعد طرفي نزاعب السودان بمزيد من
العقوبات
كوريا الشماليه تطلق صاروخا باليسيا
وجيرانها يستنفرون
علماء يبتكرون ادويه مسكنه للالم بنفايات
الورق في بريطانيا
هذه الاخبار ومواضيع اخرى ننقلها لكم من
قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد مرور نحو ثلاثه اشهر على اندلاع
النزاع في السودان وعاقبه وقف محادثات جد
كشف مصدر من وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
استعداد الولايات المتحده لاتخاذ الخطوات
اضافيه في اطار فرد العقوبات على طرفي
النزاع المسؤول الذي رفض الكشف عن اسمه
كشف ان واشنطن اتخذت خطوات لفرض عقوبات
على طرفي الصراع بما فيها ادراج اربع
شركات تابعه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
وقوات الدعم السريع على قائمه العقوبات
واعلن عن جمهوريه قرارات اخرى قائلا
مستعدون لاتخاذ خطوات اضافيه
بعد ايام من تهديدها باسقاط اي طائرات
تجسس امريكيه تنتهك مجالها الجوي اطلقت
كوريا الشماليه صاروخا باليستيا جديدا
هيات الاركان المشتركه في الجيش الكوريه
الجنوبي كشفت ان جارتها الشماليه اطلقت
صاروخا الباليسيا غير محدد باتجاه بحر
الشرق لافته الى انه تم اطلاقه بزاويه
مائله وحلق لالف كيلومتر فيما توعد رئيس
كوريا الجنوبيه بان تدفع ثمن اعمالها التي
وصفها انها غير قانونيه من جانبه اكد حرس
الحدود الياباني سقوط الصاروخ البالسي
الذي اطلقته كوريا الشماليه
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن حاله
الطوارئ في ولايه فيرموند نتيجه الامطار
الغزيره التي تسببت بفيضانات هناك كما
استدعت السلطات والقوارب والمروحيات
لانقاذ اكثر من مئه شخص وبحسب ما وصفه
مسنون في فريق البحث فانما يحصل كارثه
ومرحله بالغه الخطوره متوقعا مزيدا من
الامطار في الايام المقبله ومحذره من مزيد
من الفيضانات بسبب تشبع الارض بالمياه كما
طلبت السلطات المحليه في عده ولايات
السكان باخذ الحيطه والحذر
الى بريطانيا هذه المره حيث توصل مجموعه
من الباحثين في جامعه باست الى ابتكار
طريقه جديده لصنع اثنين من مسكنات الالم
الاكثر شيوعا
والمعروف باسمول كما قامت المجموعه
باستخراج مركب كيميائي موجود في اشجار
الصنوبر يمكن الحصول عليه من مخلفات
نفايات الصناعه الورق والذي يطلق عليه اسم
وهو ياتي من زيت تريبنتين فيما لا تزال
الابحاث جاريه لتطويرها قبل الاستفاده
منها بشكل تجاري
وفي خبرنا الاخير يبدو ان اقامه نزال
قتالي في قفص مغلق او حلب بين ماغسوغرل
وايلون ماسك ليست مسحه فمؤخرا نشر المدير
التنفيذي لميتا مارك زوكربيرج مجموعه صور
عبر حسابها على انستجرام يظهر فيها بنيه
جسديه قويه رفقه لاعبي الفنون القتاليه
عزرائيل اديسانيا والكساندر فولغانوفسكي
بعد تمرين على القتال وكان حوار على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي قدار الشهر الماضي بين
زوغورب وماسك حولي اقامه نزال بينهما